hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from the aim
chess rapid 2021
on the white end levon aronian and he's
paired against magnus carlson
i was initially drawn to this game
because of one of carlson's post-game
interviews from the event
where he described this game as
i'm paraphrasing now but he
said it came quite naturally to him
i want to see what he meant by that
and i think this game does a good job in
illustrating
two
uh key ideas
uh
one one by each side
uh
pay attention to the tempe each side
invests in the middle game and the
positive that results from each
in the end we'll see why one of the
positives
turns out to be the greater
so opening wise we have
a roy lopez
this one ends up being a
a closed system
the d-pawns are the ones that will
ultimately decide whether it turns
whether it's opened or closed
going just a single step we have
closed a board
the time controls by the way for this
game are 15 minutes
15 minutes each side
with a 10 second increment you gain 10
when you make a move
and that right there by the way if
you're looking to improve your own game
that gets my vote for one of the very
best time controls to work with
practicing
it's kind of that goldilocks zone not
too
fast not too slow
so
what's the first moment to speak of i
guess this one right here white's ready
to chop away on b5 the rooks aren't
protected
black wants to be able to maintain the
pawn on b5
so
some defense of the rook is necessary
bishop b7
simple development
d3
rook to e8
and this move 10
bishop d2 this moment here
is
really the one that i
spent the most time on i guess
in preparing for this video i had some
some questions i needed to answer for
myself so i'd like to share
some stuff here
for one
with this last move f7 is a bit more
sensitive
how are we reacting as black
if white goes for
this caveman-like idea
quick assault
against the weakest square in black's
camp
what are we doing here
of course playing as black we can repeat
we can go back to defend undo our last
move and say that this knight has really
no better than to return back into the
ball game
and
could have a repetition of position but
do we really want to be locked into that
as black
you don't have to do that
so if this move is played you can play
d5 however
proceed with caution if you're playing
as black here
because
after d5 and a capture
it's important not to recapture straight
away
the best move here is knight d4 striking
at the bishop and only a little bit
later do we go ahead and take away
in some way
on d5
what's the issue
if you go ahead and take like this well
black would find himself in some fried
liver like variation
there would be this sacrifice on f7
followed up with queen to f3 and in
order to preserve
this
knight the king has to march forward
i don't want any part of this position
playing as black
okay just a word of caution
in case there's this quick attack
against f7
in the game we have bishop to d2 so
i'm not used to seeing that move i'm
i'm used to seeing the knight make use
of that d2 square within this type of
structure
it's uh very often a nice pivot knight
d2 knight f1 where it eyes up g3
and e5 i guess really the main aim is to
eye up the f5 square with the queen
knight
so i wondered a bit about that move
it is
in my estimation
a half developing move that's how i see
it a bit of a half developing move as
well as
i think maybe
kind of waiting a little bit to see what
black's next move will be what decision
for example might
black take with the d-pawn is it going
to go one or two steps
also
note that because there is this tension
excuse me
this tension right here these two guys
this is
a candidate move
going to the edge with the knight
increasing pressure on b5 so for example
if black followed with d6 on this move
10 knight a3 is one of the better moves
and it's difficult to maintain the pawn
on b5 or at least very awkward if you're
going to
maintain the pawn on b5
and if it budges let's say with the push
this knight now
or white has
achieved
something he has gained access to an
important square c4
so
after bishop to d2 what do we have well
carlson
makes a decision with the b pawn
eliminates
the queen knight's only two options and
so
there's only going to be one way to
develop the knight it's to d2
bishop has to move
g5 it is
knight a5
two ideas here
hunting the bishop potentially
and a clearance for the c pawn to
contribute
bishop backs up
there's no time here to win the pawn
because of
this variation
black gets the pawn back
with this trick
pawn takes knight queen takes knight
this is not
looking too great here for team white
okay
bishop e2 it is
flight square
notice that the decision here on this
move 13 the bishop backs up doesn't give
up
uh the bishop for knight exchange
d6
now this is secure directly
knight to d2 where else
c5
and now on this move 15
bishop takes knight
that bishop had that option
just just a couple moves ago
why is now the moment to take on f6 why
is white going for this
what has changed
what has changed
is
the d5 square
what am i talking about
after h6
if you capture here
d5 is not a hole
a couple moves
later only after c5 the d5 square is a
whole
now white goes for this capture
why
well now this is a square that white has
in
in mind he's going to
pivot about with his minor pieces
where eventually
a minor piece will be there
and
will be able to stay there
right there's only
i mean this bishop isn't going to be
able to
ever control the d5 square these knights
will jump around and eventually one will
arrive on d5 the bishop's already there
so
we have this battle of ideas now that
surfaces
it is only at this point right here when
black has created a hole on d5 a
potential outpost for one of the white
minor pieces does white go ahead and
give up the bishop pair
and the number of tempe uh each side
invests now
is going to achieve something
for white white's gonna get something on
d5 for black what is black going to get
let's see
so first we have knight c4 some
exchanges a5 this is really
a game of inches
uh black doesn't want to see
you know this pawn even step foot on his
side of the board
so first first things first a5 it is
flight square for black exp for white
g6 these are all
pretty standard small improving type of
moves
after h4 h5
same story
you don't want to see this pawn get to
h5 can be quite disruptive
to the king side
so now the knight is maneuvering so too
is the dark square bishop to
the only open diagonal
queen f3
there is a threat now against f7 how do
we defend that well
it's rook to f8
and after knight to e3 rook to a7 so
this one right here
i thought was pretty cool
uh black recognizes
it has probably recognized for some time
now that
uh
yeah there's going to be a knight on the
d5 square
and that is usually i mean there's
plenty of example games out there strong
knight on d5
well white's going to get that
but
black's going to try and show that
there's
something more important in the position
that he's gearing up for and there it is
the break
we have yet to have a single pawn
exchange
what does this mean
no rooks are really contributing
until there's a pawn break
and
while white was investing all these
tempe into getting a minor piece
uh an unassailable minor piece on that
d5 square
black is positioning himself to
get the initial pawn break in which will
open up
activity for
both rooks and extend the scope for his
bishop pair
that turns out to be
the big difference in this one it's not
just about
extending the scope of the bishop pair
but we're getting in this pawn break and
opening up activity for the rooks
king on g7
out of the way of the bishop
it's soon gonna be
you know just staring off into space it
it does it cuts into black's position
but it's easily worked around
notice also the rook position
on a7
the bishop is ready to move and the rook
will cover conveniently many of the
a couple of the forward squares by the
night
this is kind of what we have when
two great players are going in are going
against one another something i found
uh in
you know just in improving my own game
is
you know when you observe the play of
two great players
rarely
is it going to be super one-sided and
what i mean by that is you know
one side just has
all positives and there's no positives
to speak for the other side no there's
clearly something positive
in this position for white that strong
square that piece on d5
but
this other positive this pawn break
eventually that we see with f5 and the
rooks gaining great activity
yeah that turns out to be
the bigger
positive
so
some more reorganizing
f5 is in
recapture with the rook
and
bishop to c6
clearing the way for the rook
some pressure on a4 i guess in some
lines maybe you could be
grabbing a pawn
but yeah we're controlling this knight
that's the main thing that sticks out to
me with the bishop c6 move
rook on a to e1
and
queen to a8 and i think it's it's moves
sort of like this
that
kind of have carlson describing the game
as flowing quite natural
to him
right every everything is
turning out to be quite harmonious
pretty logical here right what is
white's best piece
that guy on d5 well it's usually not a
good idea to allow that piece to sit in
my house how can i challenge it
well queen to a8 is the way to do it
maybe the only way to do it
i don't think you want to really
strike at the the knight from the other
angle right setting up yourself up for
discoveries
but yeah queen corner pocket
that night has to go
if you're going to defend it you're in a
pickle you're in a pin
okay
the night has to go
knight to e3 it is
and now
there's this big square on f3
right away it's made use of
these bishops
i could have pointed it out right here
in fact
after
we had this first pawn exchange
these bishops are really raking the
whole board
cutting into
the white side very nice
and right here after that bishop f3
queen d2
bishop's functioning on adjacent
diagonals
brutal
you'll notice that black doesn't care
about knight takes rook
it is hitting with check
let's see after queen here
black plays d5 doesn't care about this
move
because queen is dead
or you'd have to put the rook in the way
because these two bishops are
controlling all these squares
queen has nowhere to go
so what do we have after d5
eventually
that knight is going to be attacked
attack pin pieces
bishop backs up
if bishop takes pawn here yeah that's
that's nothing we just take
knight is pinned
so he backs off
he packs up with the rook right now
there's actually
this is
this is one of those points where you
could kind of
torture white a little bit just
there's no rush
this knight still can't move and
the queen yeah the knight is in a pin
and the knight can't get out of the pin
the queen can't get out of the pin in
one move
right there's there's only one safe
square for the queen but you're still in
a pin
so just calmly retreating rook to f8
and now d5 hits
the end result of this what do we have
black is now going to win
some material in the conversion there's
nothing really exciting
happening there so let's just see these
fin the finishing touches keeping it
squeaky clean
yeah stark square bishop gets on the
main diagonal now we can take on d4 with
check
there is no
no issue here if queen takes bishop
because we would have this in between
move capturing first the rook
and only then taking the queen
we're up a rook here
so
final moves rooks are off
and after the queen exchange white
resigns at this moment
nothing to do here
offering queen exchange ready to take
the pawn the other pawn
nothing to play for there's one check
if that happened if the game did
continue from here check here
no follow-up checks and
yeah it's probably looking like
checkmate soon for the white king
but this is as far as it got after queen
to f5 aronian threw in the towel
and yeah i found this one
i found this one instructive seeing
those two ideas in action
uh the idea to activate the rooks when
there wasn't a single pawn exchange that
was the bigger
uh
that was the the more important idea
in this one
anyhow as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you